let's stick with the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 next caller will be from the
4:07 area code caller from 407 introduce
yourself tell us what your question is
as well hello my name is Joe van people
call me Jojo all right yeah I was just
wondering well how do we conspiracy
theory about this entire like holding I
can't I can't hear a word that Jojo is
saying is here's the theory this he said
can we turn him up somehow I don't know
if we can try to speak up if you can
Jojo cuz I'm having a real hard time
hearing you
okay sorry my phone's one little crack
well it's kind of stupid anyways had a
weird conspiracy about this entire thing
okay
okay that's a yes
Trump is helping the Russians but not
knowing so but while the Russians know
that he is helping them they're trying
to help Korea and while they know
they're trying to help Trump because
leaders arguing to his right base who
pretty much have agreements is with a
large part of world black people Jewish
people which all over the world so he's
going to do things that aggravate those
kind of things to gain popularity
meanwhile Russia over Arabic area and
believe Asia go together neke together
for world peace but or you know peace
offering but technically under the guise
with peace offering but technically it's
a way to start the war we built from the
ashes and make the entire world
you can rule done day yeah that's kind
of crazy but yeah you like something
dictators know yeah I wouldn't even be
I'm not even sure I fully understand
that one so I don't know that I'd be
able to comment I mean Pat is there we
may need a long-form investigation on
this one yeah we might have to call in
Noah Ferguson to really look into that
one and give us 30 minutes on unpacking
at uh Jojo I couldn't possibly comment
on it but it's very interesting that
you're thinking about it and I'm
wondering what what other theories
theories you might have because that
that's definitely an interesting one I
appreciate the call very very much